اهلا بكم الى موجز الاخبار من الجزيره
توالت ردود الفعل الفلسطينيه والعربيه
والدوليه المنبذه باقتحام وزير الامن
القومي الاسرائيلي ثمار
للمسجد الاقصى المبارك اذ قالت رئاسه
الفلسطينيه ان اقتحام بنج فير للمسجد
الاقصى سيؤدي تفجير الاوضاع ودعت للتصدي
للاقتحامات كما دلت الفصائل الفلسطينيه
الاقتحام واعتبرته استفزازا غير مقبول
ينذروا بعواقبه وخيمه وقالت القناه
الرسميه الاسرائيليه ان اقتحام من فير
لباحات الاقصى جرى بالتنسيق مع رئيس
الحكومه بنيامين نتنياهو
واعلن البيت الابيض وان موقف واشنطن راسخ
بشان الحفاظ على الوضع القائم في القدس
وشدد على ان اي اجراء احادي الجانب يقبض
الوضع القائمه للاماكن المقدسه في القدس
غير مقبول وقال البيت الابيض ان واشنطن
تتوقعوا ان يفيا نتنياهو بالتزامه بعدم
تقليد الاوضاع في الاماكن المقدسه
في تونس وصفها احمد نجيب الشاب رئيس جبهه
الخلاصه المعارضه وصفاء احالته مع عدد من
عدد الجبهه للقضاء باللعبه السياسيه كما
اكد انه لن يستجيب لاي استدعاء قضائيين
وبينما شدد الرئيس التونسيه على ضروره ما
وصفت ما وصفه بتطهير البلاد من كل من
استولى على مقدراتها دعايه جمعيه القضاه
التونسيين عموما القضاه للتمسك باستقلاليه
القضاء
اعلن الجيش الاوكراني وحاله التاهب الجوي
في مقاطع
جنوب البلاد وقالت الاستخبارات العسكريه
الاوكرانيه ان القوات الروسيه ستحاول
تنفيذها هجمات جديده واسعه النقاط
هذا وقد اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
ارتفاع عدد القتلى من العسكريين الروس
نتيجه قصف مركز انتشار لهم في مكيف كابي
دونيتك الى 89 قتيلا واقل النائب الاول
لرئيس الادارات العسكريه للقوات الروسيه
ان التحقيقات الاوليه تشير الى ان استخدام
الجنود للهواتف الجواله كشفها
قال الرئيس الاوكراني بلادي من رازيلنسكي
انه بحث مع رئيس الوزراء البريطانيه ريشي
سوناك سبل تكثيف الجهود للاقتراب من النصر
الذي بتاقرب بحسب تعبيره وقالت الحكومه
البريطانيه هي سوناك كذا دعم لندن لكيف في
مواجهه الهجمات الروسيه بالطائرات المسيره
اخفق اعضاء مجلس النواب الامريكي في
التوافق على مرشح لرئاسه المجلس بعد ثلاث
جولات من التصويت ففي مشهد تاريخي لم
يتكرر منذ عام
1923 فشل زعيم الاغلبيه الجمهوريه في مجلس
النواب كيفما كارثي من تامينيا المئتين
وثمانيه عشر صوتا المطلوبه ليتولي رئاسه
وعلق المجلساته الى ظهر الاربعاء بتوقيت
واشنطن
اشكركم على متابعه الموجز السلام عليكم